today on the matt walsh show as rioters
continue to destroy minneapolis over the
death of dante wright the full truth
about wright's death
and his life is finally coming out
wright was wanted by police after
robbing a woman at gunpoint and choking
her does that detail matter
i say it does and i'll explain why plus
our five headlines including the mayor
of brooklyn center
um suggesting that cops who do traffic
stops shouldn't have guns
what could go wrong and the ap declares
that the term mistress is no longer
acceptable because
it stigmatizes floozies my word not
theirs finally in our daily cancellation
we'll talk about
something called neo pronouns if you if
you thought the left couldn't make a
bigger mess of pronouns
you were mistaken we'll talk about that
and much more today on the matt walsh
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
now quick word from legacy box you know
we all have of course memories that we
cherish and those of us who were
especially those of us who were born
maybe before our entire life moved to
the internet
a lot of those memories are going to be
stored on
on objects perishable objects maybe
maybe things that are
in an attic somewhere in a box
collecting dust or down in a basement
where they could
sustain flood damage whatever it is that
is why you need legacy box legacy box is
an effortless way to have your aging
tapes films and photos
digitally preserved in a modern format
so they're safe for generations with
legacy box you can reclaim all the
priceless footage that you haven't been
able to see in years
the service couldn't be simpler you you
use their kit to safely send the moments
that you want preserved their team will
create a digital archive by hand
then you'll receive your new copy stored
on the cloud a thumb drive a dvd
whatever you want
and with their tracking system you can
follow every step of the process so you
always know your that your originals are
being taken care of
very very easy for you i've done this
myself
and that's the one thing i was impressed
with how easy it was i just put
everything in the box said that they
sent it back
and um i could not be happier go to
legacybox.com
to join more than a million other
families who've used a legacy box for
just a fraction of the regular price
take advantage of 50 percent off today
and send in your legacy box whenever
you're ready
go to legacy box dot com slash walsh and
save 50 while supplies last
well as we know one of the very first
men canonized by the high priests of the
church of blm was
michael brown described in media reports
as a gentle giant
hailed as a promising young man a
valuable member of the community
brown died while assaulting a police
officer and trying to take his gun
george floyd whose death at the hands of
police is being adjudicated as we speak
died while resisting arrest and high on
lethal doses of fentanyl
his rap sheet included the home invasion
armed robbery of a woman
floyd held the woman at gunpoint and
robbed her one of the other men and his
crew
pistol-whipped uh the woman at some
point during the robbery jacob blake
another canonized saint for blm
though he's still alive a man who
received ceremonial visits from joe
biden and other democratic dignitaries
had
a few months before being shot by police
allegedly broke into a woman's house
and raped her in her bedroom before
stealing her debit card and her vehicle
this crime was reported on on the
morning it allegedly happened when the
woman called 9-1-1
distraught and in tears on the day of
the shooting blake had returned to the
home of his alleged victim and was
attempting to take her car keys and her
car
he fought the police when they arrived
pulled a knife and then wound up getting
shot
and then dante wright the latest martyr
that blm has chosen and i do mean
chosen as we've covered on this show
many black men die
every week in this country most of them
ignored by blm in the media many people
are killed
in altercations with police every year
not nearly as many as you may be led to
believe by the media but still
many and most of them are also ignored
by blm and the media
only certain official victims are
selected dante wright is one
we know about the circumstances
surrounding his death he was pulled over
for a minor traffic violation
initially the police discovered that he
had an open warrant
they tried to arrest him he resisted
pushed them away climbed back into his
vehicle and was shot by a female officer
who says that she
meant to use her taser not her gun we
we knew all that and now an extra piece
of the puzzle
has been revealed the daily mail has the
report so let's i'm going to read now
from the daily mail
and i want to read as much of this
report as i can because it's all
important information
um this is what they say dante wright
choked a woman and threatened to shoot
her
if she did not hand over 820 she had
stuffed in her bra
court papers obtained by dailymail.com
allege
that is the case that led to a warrant
for his arrest at the time that he was
shot and killed by police officer
kimberly potter in minnesota on sunday
leading to days of unrest
an online speculation that he didn't
know there was a warrant for his arrest
is false
dailymail.com has learned a letter
returned to the court for having a wrong
address was giving
notice of a court date in august and had
nothing to do with the warrant
wright was allegedly pulled over for
having expired license plate tags though
that we called his mother and told her
it was for having an air freshener
hanging on his rear view mirror
while checking his detail potter details
potter
and the other officers learned of the
warrant
okay then the article goes into greater
detail about the crime that led to his
warrant being issued
here are those details it says
charging papers say that he and a second
man emma j
driver went to a home shared by two
women in
aseo minnesota to party quote unquote in
december 2019.
at the time wright was 19 and driver was
18.
the women the women asked them to leave
around 2 30 a.m on december 1st but they
said they didn't have a ride and the
women
who are not identified in the court
documents allowed them to sleep on the
floor
in the morning one of the women went to
the bank to get her 820
rent money which she gave to the other
woman and then left for work
as right driver and the second woman
were leaving wright allegedly tried
tried to hold up the woman the three of
them were walking to the door to exit
the apartment and defendant right turned
around
and blocked the door preventing the
victim from leaving according to the
report written by oseo police officer
shane mickelson
defendant wright then pulled a black
handgun with silver trim
out from either his right waistband or
his right coat pocket
and pointed it at the victim and
demanded the rent money
continued mickelson the victim said are
you serious
defendant right replied give me the
effing money i know you have it
when the woman again asked him if he was
serious wright is said to have replied
i'm not playing around
nicholson report mickelson's report said
quote the 820
cash was tucked in the victim's bra and
defendant wright placed
his hand around the victim's neck and
choked her while trying to pull the cash
from under her bra
so now we've got sexual assault that we
could also add to the to the list of
what's happening here
the victim was able to get loose from
defendant right and started to kneel
down and scream after more yelling
wright allegedly told the woman
that he was going to shoot her unless he
got the money
he allegedly said quote give me the
money and we'll leave give me the money
and we'll go
mickelson added defendant right then
tried to choke victim a second time and
tried to take her money
defendant driver was telling her to give
defendant right the money
um now it goes on to explain so so just
quickly to review there
um he stated he was allowed to stay at
this woman's house
and uh and then he knew the next day
they were going to get rent money
to pay their rent and his decision was
to pull a gun
and rob them and to choke her in the
process
and then also reaching his hand into her
bra which is sexual assault on top of it
even if he wasn't charged with that
that's what that is so we've got choking
a woman sexually assaulting her
and robbing her at gunpoint to take her
her rent money
that's dante wright upstanding citizen
now it goes on to explain that the
victim reported the crime to police
easily identified right obviously as the
culprit and then he was arrested
and then this quote wright's bail was
originally originally set at a hundred
thousand dollars with orders that he
should not contact the victim or any
witness
refrain from drugs and alcohol and not
have any weapons
a bond bond male's been paid for forty
thousand dollars for his release
but his bail was revoked in july last
year due to his failure to not possess a
firearm or ammunition
and not keeping in touch with the
probation officer court paper show
at that time a judge issued a warrant
for his arrest that was still
outstanding on the day that he died
okay so the warrants
for wright's arrest was not simply
because he had a handgun without a
permit it certainly
wasn't because of an air freshener which
was the insane lie promulgated on
twitter
it was because he robbed a woman at
gunpoint and choked her
slight difference you might say
originally we were told air freshener
turns out no he robbed a woman at
gunpoint and choked her
that's why he was arrested
this means that of the three most recent
and most prominent blm martyrs the three
men blm insists we collectively wail and
mourn and honor and celebrate and whose
faces we must paint in murals and names
we must remember and repeat
all three of them all three
committed unthinkably brutal and violent
attacks against women
all three were tormentors and
victimizers of women
these are not men accused of metoo style
harassment
but of of some of the cruelest and most
vicious abuse
a person can possibly inflict on another
person
now the question does it matter
specifically for dante right does it
matter that he allegedly committed this
heinous act
well that is such a stupid question that
i almost don't want to answer it but i
will
yes it matters and it matters a lot and
for a lot of reasons
but let's focus on three first
simply it's true i mean this is the
truth the truth matters this is what
happened
we may be screamed at we may have all
kinds of labels thrown at us
for speaking the truth but the truth
remains the truth the truth is that
dante wright was wanted by the police
for robbing a woman at gunpoint and
choking her
and also sexually assaulting her that is
a truth
that in several ways contradicts blm's
narrative it's a truth
they don't want us to know or to speak
and that's why it should be known and
should be spoken the truth matters
when you say any truth and people start
screaming at you and telling you to shut
up
what that tells you is keep saying it
and say it louder
there is never a good reason
for people to try to shut down what is
true or to conceal what is true
we could leave it at that but we won't
second point as established a lot of
people die every day in this country
often unjustly usually at the hands of
another civilian but sometimes
at the hands of agents of the state of
all of that death
all of that misery all of that suffering
all of that loss
these men in particular these men
especially
are chosen by the cultural powers that
be and we are told that we should honor
and mourn them
more than we honor and mourn the average
murder victim
of which again there are thousands they
are the ones who get the politicians
weeping beside
their golden caskets they are the ones
with the murals and the streets
streets named after them our reaction to
their deaths
goes way beyond way way beyond
simply calling for accountability this
is not just that
if that's all that was happening then
the personal brutality and evil
committed by these people wouldn't be
as relevant but that's not all that's
happening not even close
they receive treatment that is very
close to worship sometimes in floyd's
case
not close to worship but but actual
literal worship and because of that
it becomes all the more necessary to
speak the truth about who these people
were
what they did the harm they caused
and to ask whether they of all people
should
be the ones with halos placed around
their heads now
um third point
finally this crime by dante wright
his armed robbery of a woman is what led
directly to his arrest
which is what led to his death it's a
part of the story inextricably
if dante wright had not robbed a woman
at gunpoint
he would be alive today that is
indisputable
and and it brings us to this fact and
here is the most forbidden truth of all
the thing that we simply are not allowed
to say
but i will say it and the truth is this
going all the way back to michael brown
and back up again to dante wright so
often the blm martyrs
are violent men bad men
who had little regard for human life and
who ultimately met the fate that so
often befalls
men of that sort does this mean that
they
deserve to die no that's not the point
okay the point is simply that when you
live that kind of lifestyle
you probably will die sooner than later
if not at the hands of police than at
the hands of another criminal on the
street
okay if you're the kind of person
who would even conceive
of pulling a gun out and robbing a woman
at gunpoint while she's trying to get
her rent money
then you are the kind of person who will
very likely die before you get old and
gray
if we don't want people like dante
wright to die
then we should tell them not to live
like he lived in the words of the gospel
live by the sword die by the sword
that's a message that stood the test of
time
and it certainly applies here now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
now we check in with our sponsors all
form yeah i consider myself to be
something of a
sofa connoisseur i'm actually very picky
about sophie's my wife
knows this has been a source of
frustration for her i can't you know
i i just i need what i'm like the
princess and the pee or something when
it comes to sofas i have a very specific
needs that i have
uh and that's why i'm so excited about
all form if you've been listening to
this show for a while you've probably
heard me talk about my helix mattress
which uh solved all of my sleeping
problems but then you have the problem
of what about the rest of the day
when you're sitting on your couch you
know so there's a sleeping or sitting on
the couch for me
helix has left the bedroom and started
making sofas they just launched a new
company called all farm and they're
already making the best sofas
we've ever seen or sat on so what makes
an all four of sofa really cool for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize your sofa use by using premium
materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
sofas you can pick your fabric the sofa
color everything you want
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone all form
sofas are also delivered directly to
your home
with fast free shipping uh so what are
you getting it's it's
it's very convenient it's fast it's
affordable
and you're just getting a sofa that is
incredibly comfortable and that's the
most important thing to me
looks great that's my wife's most
important thing with the sofa for me
i need it to be comfortable and we get
all form sofa and we get all that
together so
all form is offering 20 off all orders
for our listeners at allform.com
walsh to find your perfect sofa go check
out allform.com
walsh so the mayor of brooklyn center
has a brilliant idea about police reform
a lot of a lot of brilliant ideas about
police reform are going around
especially on the left right now
before we get to the mayor actually
rashida talib um
one one member of the squad said
a couple days ago uh announced that we
should abolish police
and abolish incarceration okay so it's
not an exaggeration to say that that she
wants to free
every prisoner in jail right now in
prison you should there's no
incarceration
let them all out of jail nobody goes to
jail
so the child molesters and child rapists
uh they get to
get out of jail that's what rashida
talib wants to free
every child rapist from prison that is
an accurate statement
um now i mean it is it is sort of
interesting in in her case
that she says she wants to abolish
incarceration abolish the police
um did i'll go back and check does
anyone remember rashida talib
speaking out against the incarceration
of the protesters on january 6 at
capitol hill
what did she have to say about that
because
they're being hunted down and thrown in
prison
sometimes getting lengthy prison
sentences uh or
or you know charges that carry lengthy
prisoner sentences put on their head
and has rashida she wants to abolish
incarceration shouldn't she should she
be speaking out against that no i don't
think so
because of course when she says abolish
incarceration we know
that that she means that in a very
selective way
she wants to abolish incarceration for
certain people
it's not even just it's not that she
wants to abolish incarceration
for certain crimes no it's for certain
people shouldn't go to jail no matter
what they do
that's her view the mayor of uh brooklyn
center has a view that
is nearly as crazy and let's listen to
what he has to say
uh and uh make sure that you know we sit
down and
and and go through it and and see how we
can implement
uh i i don't believe that officers need
to necessarily
uh have weapons uh
you know uh every time they they're
they're making a traffic stop
uh or or engaged in
uh situations that
don't necessarily call for uh for
weapons
we know that there are other many other
jurisdictions or even around the world
where
that is not you know necessarily the
case it's not needed
you know i don't believe that
construction workers
necessarily need hard hats
uh you know i don't get i think they
look stupid in the hard hats it's silly
oh you guys i mean you're on your
construction's like how often does
something fall on your head right it
doesn't happen all that often
you don't need a hard hat all the time i
mean i'm not on the construction site
and i need the people on the
construction site to build stuff so that
i can you know
take advantage of the things they build
but i'm going to sit off on my couch
and drink a beer and start
start giving my opinion about the safety
measures taken by construction workers
look at that when they're stupid hard
hats
is the exact same thing kind of thing
here now he's he's standing off on the
sideline and saying
they don't need guns what do they need
that for
yeah attra any any cop knows that a
traffic stop can turn
fatal for the officer in a split
second and what
this this happens a lot
you know you can go online and find
video you're not going to find a lot of
news articles about this kind of thing
because the media doesn't report on that
but if you if you go and look you can
find and you want to see it
you can find video dash cam footage and
so forth
officers in a normal traffic stop you
know enforcing
a traffic regulation next you know
they're getting shot at
now the mayor of brooklyn center his
view
is that if if you start if a cop is
getting shot at during traffic stop well
you just have to die that's all just die
i mean i guess you could surrender
go down to your knees put your hands up
apologize
you could try to make a run back to your
car and hide
but you know maybe he'll just die you
know he doesn't care if police die he
really doesn't
democrats in general don't
they they it makes no difference to them
they do not care the the lives of police
officers mean nothing to them
in fact in many cases they're happy when
cops die
which is why you know you remember i
said a couple months ago with officer
brian siknik
at the capitol who by the way we still
have not been told
what exactly you know how officer
sicknick died we were told by the media
immediately
that he was killed by a protester at the
capitol but
somehow even though he was murdered and
the media knew that right away
nobody's been charged with murdering him
we do know that that the other deaths
remember we were told
now i'm getting sidetracked a little bit
we were told by the media that
the riot on capitol hill was a deadly
riot and five people died
well the medical examiner in dc last
week finally came out
and admitted that three of the deaths
were medical emergencies
in fact well two were you know heart
conditions medical emergence people with
medical conditions
tragically died another person died of a
drug overdose
okay so those were counted in the tally
for five that's how they got to the
deadly riot
then another person ashley babbitt was a
homicide victim she was killed by a
capital police officer
and then we have brian sickner we're not
being told anything about him the only
confirmed homicide
in the quote deadly riot was the
homicide that a
that a protester was a victim of
but in any case brian siknik you know um
however he died it's a terrible tragic
thing and
the democrats and the media are
mourning officer sicknick calling for
flags to be at half-staff talking about
the great service that he provided for
the community talking about how he
feel for his family and his wife and his
children and of course
yes that it is a terrible tragedy and
the flag
should be flawed at half-mast and we do
feel terrible for his family
the difference is though that the
democrats saying that they don't really
mean it i don't believe
and i didn't believe then for a second
that they actually cared about brian
sicknick's death
because he's the only cop
that these democrats
i was running through a number of names
i could i just decided to go with
democrats
he's the only cop that they pretended to
care about
many cops have died over the last five
years
can you think of any other police
officer
that the majority of democrats you know
were publicly mourning
out of all the police officers who have
died
so on um on the rare occasion
when mourning a police officer's death
is politically expedient and convenient
for the democrats that's when they
pretend to care
but in every other case they couldn't
give a less of a damn
um all right speaking of
of not caring if police officers die or
if people die in general
chelsea handler tweeted this she says
why would any person of color ever
comply with a police officer when
there's a 50 50 shot
of getting accidentally shot
accidentally in quote
quotes 50 50. this tweet
bunch of retweets people liking it
commenting oh this is real yup
amen to that this is uh chelsea handler
trying to get people killed
specifically trying to get young black
men killed that's what she's doing
you might as well not comply because
there's a 50 50 chance that you're
50 50. where are you getting that
statistic from
50 chance well she's pulling it from her
fevered imagination
it's not based in reality whatsoever it
also doesn't even make sense i mean
even if i were to put aside the insane
50 percent
statistic that she's made up
don't she's she's claiming that
you're likely to get shot if you comply
so you may as well
not what
in in almost every case of a person
doesn't matter what their race is
getting shot by the cops
it's when they're not complying
dante wright was getting arrested and
was not in any
physical danger whatsoever they were
cuffing him they weren't even yelling at
him or anything they were cuffing him
they're going to bring him to the police
car
that was all fine it's when he started
resisting arrest that is how
he ended up getting shot
so you might as well not comply because
you're going to get shot anyway
really i mean of the from the last 10
years
how many cases can you provide how many
examples can you provide
of somebody who was not resisting arrest
and was complying
and yet got shot and killed by the cops
anyway i know you can point to a few
examples
and in nearly all of those small that
small small sliver that small
small minority of cases and almost all
of them the police officer
involved uh goes to jail
i mean um there was the dallas police
officer the bathroom gene
in i think it was in dallas he was he
was in his own
apartment when an off-duty police
officer walked in and shot him she
thought it was her own
apartment she says terrible tragedy
horrible horrible thing she went to
prison she was going to prison for 10
years for that
in in nearly every case
uh when someone gets shot by the cops
it's because they're not complying
now because they are chelsea handler she
may be a total [ __ ] but she she knows
that
she also knows that 50 50 is is
something that she made up
but she doesn't you know it's it is it
works for her ideologically when young
black men get killed by the police so
she's she's fine with it continuing to
happen
blm activist kim brown i wanted to play
this clip for you as well
um she's on a i think this is her own
show which
yeah okay this is called burn it the
name of her podcast or show or youtube
show whatever it is it's called burn it
down so you kind of get an idea of where
she's coming from
and uh here's what she had to say making
an eloquent case in favor of rioting and
looting let's listen to that
i support all that i support them
looting
the the dollar tree i support the
looting of
uh what other did they loot uh like the
like the advanced auto parts
um i remember last year they looted
target i support audit
loot audit do you know why because black
people
and marginalized and oppressed people
could loot
every store in this whole country for
200
years it would not even come close to
the debt
that america owes us okay
yeah um so that that is full-throated
defense of rioting and looting
we hear that all the time from blm
activists
this is not shocking at all it's not
just that they're doing it but they
support it in principle and will
explicitly defend it
and will do so publicly without apology
and yet we're still told that the blm
movement is mostly peaceful
so peaceful movement the fact that
they're both looting and writing and
defending it and encouraging it and
saying do it more
uh yeah you're not supposed to hear that
the the just ignore that part
of course that what she just what she
said there uh is
wrong on so many levels and you we we
could spend all day
uh dissecting it and and tearing it
apart but
let's start with one really basic thing
here
that she claims that she is owed a debt
from america
she's wrong about that can we
america doesn't owe you anything
whatever your race is you're not you're
not owed anything simply for existing
okay we're not we're not in debt to you
society is not in debt to you
and again i don't care what your race is
society is not in debt to you
and but if you live like that with that
kind of mentality then this is what you
end up with
and if enough people live like that with
that mentality you end up with rioting
and looting
but even if america did in in some
mysterious way
uh collectively owe you a debt
why are you taking out taking it out on
the dollar tree or auto zone
how do they owe it to you the people who
work there
many of them minorities that
so you're you're taking at this this
debt that you think really white
america owes you you're taking it out on
your own community
the dollar tree in minneapolis that's
not white america that you're that
you're tearing down it's not capitalism
that you're tearing down
it is your own community that you're
victimizing
people in your community work there
people in your community depend on that
place they go and they shop there
you you tore it apart and burned it down
so even on your own logic it doesn't
make any sense
but there really is no logic at all so
at the end of the day it's simply
destruction for destruction's case and
um
and for looters yeah the the motivation
for most looters of of
of all stripes is simply uh i could get
free stuff and i want free stuff
it does doesn't go much doesn't get much
deeper than that i think for the average
looter all right uh let's move on to
this from the daily wire it says
as female athletes around the country
fight to keep biological men from
competing with them
the national collegiate athletic
association ncaa has announced its
unequivocal support for transgender
student athletes in a statement released
on monday
the ncaa said it unequivocally supports
the transgender community
and expressed no misgivings about the
real prospect of biological men
out-competing women in their given sport
it says the ncaa board of governors
firmly
and unequivocally supports the
opportunity for transgender student
athletes to compete in college sports
this commitment is grounded in our
values of inclusion and fair competition
fair cup this is their values of fair
competition the fact that they value
fair competition is why they're okay
with biological men competing against
women because
of fair competition the ncaa continued
um the ncaa has a long-standing policy
that provides a more inclusive path for
transgender participation in college
sports
our approach which requires testosterone
suppression treatment for transgender
women to compete in women's sports
embraces the evolving science on this
issue and is anchored in participation
policies of both the international
olympic committee
and the u.s olympic and paralympic
committee inclusion and fairness can
co-exist for all student-athletes
including transgender athletes at all
levels of sports
and it goes on for there with from there
um
all of it just doesn't go incoherent is
what i what i just read to you
uh first of all
as always this is being framed as
oh we have to make sure that transgender
people can compete in sports
well no there was never a point where
they couldn't compete
no one is saying that they can't compete
that is not a position that anyone holds
at least i've never heard it have you
i've never heard anyone
certainly anyone in any position of
power or authority stand up and say that
transgender people should not be allowed
to compete in sports period no one's
saying that
all we're saying is that everyone
doesn't matter how you identify
everyone can compete against their own
biological sex
that is inclusion and that's equality
same policy for everyone everyone is
welcome
same policy for everyone same rules for
everyone
inclusion fairness equality all of that
when you start putting men in against
women in women's sports
that is not you embracing equality
fairness and inclusion but that is you
getting rid of
equality fairness inclusion all right
uh what else do we have here
this is from the new york post it says
new york state senator julia salazar
a democrat from brooklyn says an older
male colleague once told her that she
looked like a bond girl
while in the legislative chamber salazar
30 recalled the encounter
in a new york times article published
monday that detailed albany's
toxic environment for women she told the
newspaper it seemed odd for my male
colleague to say that
salazar who joined the colleague the
legislature in 2000 2019 said the
republican senator
randomly made the comment as they sat
near each other in the chamber she asked
that the senator who has since retired
not be identified
she also remembered another incident in
which a fellow legislator staffer made
inappropriate comments to her at a 2019
fundraiser
he said quote you should be on a
calendar
and she said she was so embarrassed that
she left
well look i think we should be
sympathetic um to
the men who said these comments to julia
salazar because they're already blind
and let's not add insult to injury for
them
that was me that's a joke i don't even
know what julia salazar looks like i'm
sure she's a good-looking woman i have
no idea
i just i can't see i i can't
bring myself to see how a compliment
could be embarrassing and traumatizing
that you would even remember it two
years later and you're reporting it to
the newspaper
and how it counts as harassment i'm
trying to think back in my own life
i don't think i've ever received a
compliment
yeah i don't think i've ever received a
compliment that traumatized me i don't
think i've ever received a compliment
that upset me
i don't know if i've ever received a
compliment i thought to myself you know
i really wish that person hadn't
complimented me like that
now granted i don't receive a lot of
compliments so you know i don't know
maybe if you're so privileged that you
get complimented all the time after a
while you get sick of it
i'm not sure finally this is the ap
style guide they uh they had this they
tweeted this
on um tuesday they said don't use the
term mistress for a woman who is in a
long-term sexual relationship with and
is financially supported by a man who is
married to someone else
instead use an alternative like
companion friend or lover
on first reference and provide
additional details later
companion or friend yeah don't use um
don't use mistress i think the preferred
term is homewrecking hussy
i believe which even there
you know i i only use that because it's
an alliteration and it's fun
alliterations are fun
i this is maybe my most feminine this is
the most feminist opinion you'll ever
hear me
give i actually don't like hussy is fine
for for anyone involved in an affair um
and mistress is fine too
and um really people that are involved
in affairs are there's like no insult
that is beneath them but i don't i don't
love the term homewrecker
for the woman in that scenario the
mistress
for the married man because
she's not really the one it's the guy is
the one wrecking his own home
he's the one who made the undying
commitment to his
to his wife uh and to his family and
and he is now violating that and
choosing to destroy his own home and his
own and
you know in his marriage his children's
lives i mean
he's potentially putting his children's
childhood and everything on the line
for the sake of this sexual trust so
i will say you know i think
it's unfair to put home record on the
woman there it should really go to the
man
maybe that's the way to break this up
the woman is is the mistress the man is
the home wrecker there we go
compromise you see it is possible
all right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments it says this is from
john says i was a roofer for 20 years
and i never encountered
one that was a female i've seen a few
ladies that cleaned the ground around
the job site though
yeah we were talking about the issue of
representation
and how it's it's it's it's funny how
we're told there needs to be more
minority and female representation
in jobs like like in places like
hollywood okay
and those kinds of really um
those kinds of jobs that society tends
to to value
even incorrectly or disproportionately
but you never hear anyone
complain that there are no female
roofers or very few
or garbage collectors i actually looked
this up after the show because i was
curious
and not surprisingly 90 of garbage
collectors are men
and close to 70 are white so this is a
white male occupation
the people that are cleaning your
garbage are by and large
white males ah that no no one ever
complains about that no one ever talks
about
minority and female representation among
garbage collectors i wonder why that is
de devil of mine username says come on
now matt you don't like animals that's
fine but when you killed the fish you
had an opportunity to teach
your daughter about a few things most
importantly i think is how to respect
nature if you killed it you clean it you
take it home and you eat it
this way the death isn't in vain it was
a possible learning moment but your
actions
led to either her not respecting animal
life or the opposite and go full vegan
yeah my my daughter announced that she
was going vegetarian and then you know
last week
and it ends up that she's actually a
meat-eating vegetarian which is fine
that's the only kind of vegetarianism
that i can respect
i'm tracing that back and trying to
figure out how did she become a
burgeoning animal rights activist
and uh as i said
in the summer we were we were going
fishing and she she caught a bluegill
like a small sunfish and accidentally
killed it when she was looking at taking
the hook out of the mouth
tossed it back in it bubbled to the
surface and was floating there
and she was traumatized by it why didn't
we um well have you ever
a bluegill is it's just not worth the
effort there's there's like no meat on
those bones at all
and actually so here's i didn't even
tell the full story um
she throws the fish in bubbles to the
surface it's floating there
and she says daddy why why is the fish
doing that and at first i did lie and i
said oh he's taking a nap
resting and then the blood started
coming out of its mouth that's a dead
giveaway and she said why is it bleeding
and i said okay yeah it's dead
you probably killed it it's okay though
she runs off
and is really really upset and i follow
her
well i didn't follow her right away but
i was because i i just got in a bite i
was fishing in some weeds and i wanted
to make sure that
i wanted to try to catch the fish before
but i did i did after a few minutes
follow her
to console her and um i went up and i
found her she was really upset
and i i just i kept digging the hole
deeper i was trying to find the right
thing to tell her so the first thing i
said to her was
uh listen you know it yeah the fish died
but
another fish will come or maybe a turtle
or a bird will come and eat that fish
and so we're providing a meal for the
wildlife
in in the like and that made her
10 times more upset because apparently
she had in her mind
that um that that the the
the fish's family would come and like
give it a fish burial that's what she
that's what she thought that she was
consoling herself with that thought
and i ruined that so it was one thing
after another i was giving her a lot of
very good zoological information
in my process of trying to console her
and it wasn't working and
eventually she did get past it though
but apparently didn't get fully past it
and
now she's a pseudo-vegetarian so now is
my time to tell you again about
constitutioncoach.com and i'll start off
by
reminding you that they've got another
this is the most important thing they've
got a class
on april 25th filling up very fast
they've only got a few spots left so if
you want to be a part of this experience
you got to go to constitutioncoach.com
my friends over at constitutioncoach.com
have
many wonderful programs for equipping
citizens to defend liberty by studying
and living out the constitution
and what you're getting is you're
getting the intellectual ammunition with
the constitution
classes you're also getting physical
training at the premier firearms
training facility
in the nation more and more people are
becoming gun owners which is fantastic
exercising their second amendment rights
more more people are carrying guns uh
another fantastic thing
so you're equipped to defend yourself
and defend your family but if you're
going to do that and this is the
realization that i had and why
and this is why i was so excited to be a
part of this training for
constitutioncoach.com but i realize if
i'm going to do that i need to be well
trained you know
for my own sake for my family's sake
it's it's my responsibility
and also it's just it's a lot of fun too
being there you get the fellowship with
like-minded people
um so it's just a great all-around
package don't just get a gun learn how
to carry with confidence and get the
training that you need to defend your
family go to constitutioncoach.com
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th it's
filling up fast so you got to go now
constitutioncoach.com
now it's already episode five um of the
candace owens show we can't get enough
of candace owens
if you haven't checked it out yet i
don't know what you're waiting for the
fearless thought leader
hosts a lively series of guests each
week plus the they got interviews and
cancel corner all kinds of great stuff
this week she'll be hosting comedian and
podcaster adam corolla
so you got to tune in because you don't
want to miss this conversation if you
need some candice owens in your podcast
feed look no further head over to apple
podcast or spotify and subscribe today
and be sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
you know i grew up as a marginalized and
persecuted minority
in my own home as i was the middle child
with four sisters two older two younger
i do have a brother too but he's the
youngest of the bunch considerably
younger than me what this meant is that
for much of my early childhood i was the
lone male
sibling against the world i actually
tried to explain to my parents on
several occasions that i was a
marginalized and persecuted minority but
they had trouble hearing me
above their own laughter when i was
trying to explain that one of the many
great
struggles of this suppressed status for
me was that my sisters especially the
older two used to make up secret
languages so that they could communicate
around me without me knowing what they
were saying
now it didn't dawn on me at the time and
i only realized later in life
that they were probably speaking pure
gibberish that neither of them
understood and this was all an
act you know to torment their poor
younger brother
it seems unlikely that they actually
devised a grammatically consistent and
intelligible language in their spare
time you know
i mean they were they were they were
gifted but i don't think they were that
gifted
in any case this is all i guess a long
way of saying
that i have been annoyed and frustrated
by made up fake
gibberish pseudo-language since a very
young age
you could even say traumatized by it and
somehow i haven't escaped it even as an
adult
as this recent article in the new york
times attests the article which we can
assume
is not meant to be satire has the
headline quote
a guide to neo pronouns
and the subhead asks the question are
you a person place or thing
we have good news now you have to keep
reading to find out whether you are
indeed a person or perhaps a sea sponge
or a skyscraper could be anything
reading on it says non-binary pronouns
often the singular they and them have
become widespread a 2019 research study
found already that
one in five americans knew someone who
uses non-binary pronouns
and then there are neo pronouns a neo
pronoun can be a word
created to serve as a pronoun without
expressing gender
like zay and zur a neopronoun can also
be a so-called
noun self pronoun in which a
pre-existing word is drafted into use as
a pronoun
noun self pronouns can refer to animals
so your pronouns can be
bun slash bun self and kittens slash
kitten self
others refer to fantasy characters vamp
vampself
prin princess self and
fey fair face elf or even just common
slang like in it in its in itself
now uh we're informed that this is all
very serious
and if you don't show proper respect for
this insanely stupid gobbley [ __ ]
you will cause great pain and suffering
to people
or to places and things as the case may
be it continues quote
a popular twitch sweet streamer who goes
by andy vmg
recently apologized after jokingly
tweeting that her pronouns were
bad slash af which led many neop neo
pronoun users to accuse her of
transphobic invalidation
of their identities andyvmg did not
respond to a request for comment for
this article but wrote on twitter quote
it wasn't meant to mock people who used
neo pronouns however i have since
educated myself on the matter and spoken
to people who use neopronouns
and i see why what i said was hurtful
of course you know there's no reason
that her pronouns can't be
bad slash af that's no more ridiculous
or illegitimate than
kitty slash kitty self or bun slash
bun self i mean by the way does the
latter mean that someone is
actually identifying as a hot dog bun i
you know i don't know
and it gets even more deranged okay for
the record
here are just some of the additional neo
pronouns that the article lists
and i'm choosing these at random there
are like dozens and dozens but firs
so let's go through a few first we have
all the basic non-binary pronouns you
know
zee zem zerzerself is ver verself
a bunch of other made up terms that
sound like something that maybe dr seuss
might have invented
if he was high on crack the sad thing is
that these pronouns are now basically
old-fashioned and traditional
these are your grandmother's pronouns or
will be somebody's grandmother's
pronouns in our not too distant
dystopian future
then there are the the the real
innovations you have the animal themed
pronouns
self and woof woof's woof self
among others then cat themed pronouns
for the crazy cat lady in your life
meow slash muse slash meow self
also there's weather themed pronouns if
anyone happens to identify as a cloud
they could be cloud slash cloud self or
if they're feeling a bit warm they could
be sun slash sun self
there's also robot themed pronouns if
they're a robot psi
cyber cyber self there's horror themed
pronouns han slash haunts
slash haunt self and uh it goes on and
on
this this is again all of this very real
okay well not real per se the pronouns
don't reflect any actual physical
reality of course
they certainly don't reflect the proper
rules of grammar but it's real in the
sense that we are all supposed to
actually take this seriously
the article explains quote neo-pronoun
users may publish strict
boundaries and preferences around
behaviors enthusiasms and hatreds
many of them have defined lists of
behaviors they find unacceptable
around privacy or cruelty and then they
go on to uh to list
those those uh behaviors sometimes
referred to as dni lists
short for do not interact which they
often outline in posts on
card a service that makes single page
websites
now we're exposed expected to follow
these rules lest we be guilty of
invalidating somebody's identity
the term invalidating identity comes up
more than once in the article
it's a major concern among all
proponents of left-wing gender theory
they are at once we are told totally
secure and happy in their identities but
also
if you use the wrong word in their
presence it may invalidate their
identity and send them into an
existential crisis
so while they are so confident and happy
in their identity
they are also utterly dependent on you a
stranger to
legitimize that identity now that seems
like it doesn't make sense that because
that's because it doesn't none of this
does it is all one big
out of control incoherent tornado of
crazy
until you realize what's really going on
here
this is narcissism now it's not just
narcissism of course a whole cocktail of
mental illness has contributed to the
proliferation
of all these fake pronouns and all of
this made up language but at bottom
there's narcissism
these are people who believe two things
one
that their inner self their inner
identity is so
complex so interesting so fascinating
so mysterious and poetic that they need
to invent new words to describe it
billions of people through the history
of the world have made do just fine with
he and she but their own inner life is
so deep and rich and ineffable
that they need to reinvent the english
language just to do it justice
everyone else can be a myself but i have
to be a
zay self what's the difference between a
myself and a zay self well
there is no difference at all whatsoever
except my own assumption
that whatever i feel must be totally
different in kind from what everyone
else has felt
of course when someone says something
like i don't feel like a hymn
i feel like a they that statement cannot
mean
anything how do they know what a hymn is
supposed to feel like
whatever they're feeling how do they
know that that's not
a him feeling they can only feel what
they feel they have nothing to compare
it to
no way to make these judgments they only
have their assumption
that they are people of greater depth
and complexity than the average person
now needless to say this is all beside
the point however you feel even if it is
different
it has no bearing on language pronouns
are not supposed to describe
your feelings pronouns are not a
reflection of your inner perception of
yourself
they're a reflection of physical reality
they don't work any other way
but the narcissist doesn't understand
that and that brings us to point two
you know we have long since moved beyond
the days where our job was to simply
let people live their own lives and let
them do what they want in their own
bedrooms and
you know tolerate their lifestyles and
refrain from interfering
those days are gone those days have come
to an end and uh we're always going to
come to an end
because now we're admonished not simply
to tolerate alternate lifestyles but to
actively at all times
in all ways validate those lifestyles
prop them up support them indeed
the construction and maintenance of
someone else's identity
is partially your responsibility if
someone says that they are a
zay self or a cat self or whatever it's
your duty
and they'll be quick to remind you of
this to actively reinforce
their perception of themselves
their self-perception is now a group
project and you are part of the group
whether you like it or not your own
identity your own priorities your own
preferences
values beliefs ideas feelings uh are
totally irrelevant
this is all about them or zim or webb or
phlegm
the whole gang it's all about narcissism
narcissism dressed up in a million
costumes and going by a million
different pronouns
but still there underneath it's the same
old thing
and that is why neo pronouns are
certainly with a vengeance cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show democrats
pursue new police standards while
promoting myths about how policing
actually works
the chauvin trial continues and the
biden administration hits the pause
button on the johnson and johnson
vaccine that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen